8 milliards d'euros sur quatre ans sur
des thèmes comme la petite enfance
l'emploi les aides sociales le logement
emmanuel macron a présenté son plan
pauvreté c'était en fin de semaine
dernière il s'agit de prévenir la
précarité et d'actionner des leviers
pour en sortir le plus vite possible
bonjour mario mauro bonjour toute la
matinée
vous êtes syndicaliste cdmt à pôle
emploi travailleur social militant
associatif la pauvreté l'insertion vous
connaissez est ce que ce plan vous
paraît suffisant celui que nous a énoncé
la semaine dernière emmanuel macron à
l'évidence qu'on annonce humilia il nie
d'euros on peut penser en parlant de
milliards que ce serait suffisant mais
qu'en fait le paramétrage budgétaire est
la déclinaison région par région
territoire par territoire
on va s'apercevoir qu'on sera au tour de
30 millions d'euros sur quatre ans pour
la martinique moins de 10 millions avec
l'ampleur de la pauvreté de la misère
dans le pays parce que il faut dire aux
martiniquais chez la pauvreté surtout
deux cent mille personnes
donc quand nous sommes une population de
390 millions voiliers de l'ampleur nous
sommes déjà sur près de 33% de la
population et que nos étudiants
profondeur l'éclat le type de pauvreté
de misère que nous avons nous l'avons
une misère pauvreté structurelle
ça a été très compliqué inverser la
tendance dont cet argent ne serait pas
suffisant et puis je veux des aussi un
préalable que le gouvernement non plus
ne peut pas casser le droit des citoyens
les emmenant vers la pauvreté de la
misère et de l'autre côté avec le bras a
mené les sparadraps l'ambulance pour dit
on va vous guérir avec un plein de powe
et équipe vous savez être insuffisant
mario bros
30 40 millions pour la martinique il en
faudrait combien trois fois plus qu à
oui il faudra trois fois plus il
faudrait il me semble une science varna
l'ambition comme il a dit j'ai bien
écouté l'éradication de la pauvreté de
la mise en pratique ce environ 100
millions d'euros pour déjà commencé
parce que on va non seulement devoir
agir sur la personne le capital humain
on va devoir martinique il faut le dire
voir comment renforcer les effectifs des
structures et moderniser la
structuration des personnes qui doivent
d
l'entité qui doivent accompagner le
retour quelle est la priorité
mario mauro il faut déjà faire un état
des lieux j'imagine qu'il existe 150
mille rapport sur la situation
ou bien déjà voir dans quelle fête où on
va mettre tous les ingrédients pour
pouvoir tenter de faire une belle
recette
oui parce que nous avons plusieurs
indications qui conduisent à la pauvreté
à la misère là le premier majeur c'est
quand un territoire est mal développée
par suivi la main développés n'ont pas
forcément des aimants de croissance des
demandeurs d'activités qui vont conduire
les gens pètent dans ce lieu à l'emploi
etc et ça va poser un problème
un deuxième lieu la question du chômage
massif en martinique aujourd'hui 58
mille personnes et quand nous regardons
le chemin de l'autre duo qui avoisine
les 30 mille on s'aperçoit bien qu'elle
pourrait s'élever à l'exclusion
cette exclusion qui conduit rsa et qu'on
est plus rsa et bien c'est une
complication majeure pour le
martiniquais et ensuite nous avons la
vie chez a aussi qui ne permettent pas
des petites pièces haut niveau dit gens
de se trouver de s'alimenter excita de
ceux nourris accéder à sa part d'un vrai
problème c'est qu'on avait tout trouvé
en 2009
oui non mais en avait on a en effet fait
effectivement il fallait mettre
je pense 2009 avait été très utile je
veux rappeler ici on parle très souvent
de 2009 comme est-ce que ça a été réçu
repas mais les indicateurs en 2008
étaient au rouge et on savait bien que
ça n'allait pas et ça a donné naissance
à 2008 2009 et une indication pour
montrer l'ampleur du phénomène et que
nous regardons aussi mais il faut avoir
le courage de dire combien de
municipalités sont en déficit budgétaire
presque 90 poussé plus de se battre et
de porter le plan pauvreté celle qu'on
laisse le souhaitait parce qu'il faut un
moment donné avant une réponse à cette
problématique est bénigne son parti et
il me semble que les moyens mis la base
de plans pauvreté et ne suffisant pas
content tu veux le temps quand on l'a on
n'entendait que la plante pour voter
avec tout ce qu'il ya dedans toutes les
mesures qui sont à l'intérieur de ce
plan peuvent être des mesures utiles
qu'en dit il faut avec des palettes que
les enfants à la cantine chez nous parce
que on sait qu'il ya beaucoup ça c'est
pour la france on sera incapable de
faire repas pour des scolaires hameau de
la suisse hyper fenêtre nos
problématiques sont plus importantes que
celles de la france
il faut gaza si ces néo en france il
faudra soit gratuit en martinique
vous dites vous disent qu'il faut
d'abord mettre l'accent sur tout ce
réseau de structures qui vont intervenir
pour combattre la pauvreté sur le
terrain c'est-à-dire l'ingénierie et à
une question d'un gène m et à une
question le compositionnel de d'entités
je vends un exemple et ses 16 des villes
qui relève de la ville si les villes
sont dites en déficit le sujet sur les
complications suffit pas de mettre de
l'argent pour que ça arrange il faut
renforcer les effectifs il faut
moderniser la capacité d'intervention
d'une entité
pour répondre à cette question il faut
former le personnel aux formes et les
personnels seraient quand même
l'impression que parfois ça on parle pas
le même langage
nam m je suis très pragmatique on peut
nous offrir les jeunes donnent pas le
contenant lever tout comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure au risque de ne pas
manger donc immeubles sont aujourd'hui
il faut prendre la mesure de la pauvreté
de la misère martinique mais il faut se
structurer pour éperonner dois faire ça
qui doit faire son job et non et c'est
une préoccupation citoyenne
à mon avis aujourd'hui en 2018 le
martiniquais
j'aime bien
cette année ce sont là les quelques il
l'a fait martine qu'elle devrait
répondre être résolus par les
martiniquais par contre les moyens
la question des moyens il faut que les
matches qu'elles sont en capacité
d'aller chercher les mains cette
question le plan de pauvreté ne peut pas
tomber là comme ça il faut absolument
qu'ils aient des discussions qui est une
passionnée navette avec le gouvernement
pour dire que cela pour pouvoir y voilà
ce que nous voulons pour la martinique
et aujourd'hui nous avons excusez moi si
nous avons des élus même s'ils n'ont pas
de moyens dans leur municipalité mais au
moins sur cette question les élus
peuvent se mettre d'accord pour discuter
de cette question devant des
parlementaires
et c'est maintenant faut-il attendre qui
est un mouvement citoyen faute de les
avoir en tant qu'un nouveau 2009 allait
discuter sur la pauvreté de la misère de
martin kelly martinique dans le cocktail
dans le cocktail explosif de mario mauro
la martinique est territoire avec une
population vieillissante on a évoqué une
jeunesse s'est fracassée par le chômage
et puis il ya là le statut de mots de
cette question de la monoparentalité ça
aussi ça accentue le où ce facteur
pauvreté quand nous avons regardé
étudier la question là pour voter avant
nous pensions que y'avait que les
familles nombreuses personnes des
familles qui pourrait poser des
problèmes pas et qui conduirait à la
pauvreté aujourd'hui on avait la
composition de la famille à la
monumentalité pour le pas et ça rend
seulement des personnes pauvres ça rend
sa tâche particulièrement des familles
ça au nom aussi pop des enfants et pour
preuve la réponse donnée aux dans les
cantines shalev de la monoparentalité
est un drama matinée et nous avons aussi
à notre drame c'est que nous commençons
à voir leurs codes jeunes filles mères
qui étaient autour de saison n'est pas
non plus vers 15 ans aujourd'hui ce ces
questions et on s'interroge même pas
avoir aux discussions aux ambiguïtés
législatives que nous entendons tous des
différentes là pour dire quoi il faut
qu'un enfant j'ai enfin consentants et
que dire après
être mère il faut éclaircir la situation
il faut éduquer et jacky toi qui doit se
charger de cela assombrit les parents
c'est d'école c'est tout le monde
aujourd'hui j'attends pas un moment
qu'on incrimine des femmes des familles
excusez moi j'aime mon pays il faut que
ces personnes analyse le pays
aujourd'hui que vous avez des jeunes
femmes qui ne sont même pas encore qui
n'ont pas fini leur adolescence qui ne
sont même pas encore en âge de
responsabilité on parle de réseau la d2
part de qui parle-t-on quand d'amendé
famille fracassé qui sont au chômage
depuis de nombreuses années qu'ils
perdent là peut-être qu'ils ne savent
pas par quel saint se vouer
on pas des responsables des banques
aujourd'hui fort est un petit peu de
sérieux
il faut aller voir ce qui se passe dans
les familles il faut accompagner les
familles laissées la seule
responsabilité
parce qu'aujourd'hui les rapports le
disent les amalgames des demi-droits
accompagner socialement faut bien
constater les chiffres que vous nous
avons deux institutions une qui
s'appelle éducation nationale pour tout
ce qui est la scolarité l'éducation
milieu scolaire et nous avons une grosse
gaffe qui porte la politique de la
famille en martinique dos plat il me
semble nous sommes dans le giron de
l'état
mais je ne veux pas que ça soit monsieur
le préfet forcément qu'il y avait des
problèmes
il faut que nos élus il faut que
l'action citoyenne se mettre en bonne
place les autres ces questions
aujourd'hui la classe politique partie
caisse frileuse sur cet aspect des
choses
par moment on n'entend pas par moments
les légers luh sur des questions cliquez
boulot possible dès lors qu'on dit que
c'est la politique légale de l'étonnante
en personne ce n'est pas normal et neuf
sur le chômage massif qu'on se cache
derrière l'état pour se dire qu'on ne
fait rien parce que c'est d'état et
j'entends ces mêmes personnes qui
accompagnent électeurs venus du marais
battre travail non mais c'est une honte
bien vous une vraie ambiguïté dont il
faut clarifier pour moi aujourd'hui
il faut que tout le monde y est il faut
que les matines qui se mobilisent sur
ces questions-là élus parlementaires les
sites des mouvements citoyens de plus en
plus on monte
l'état aussi je vois je dis que c'est
monsieur aubine le préfet de la marne
que je salue parsons qui mène la
martinique où sont nos élus nous sommes
dans des crises politiques
invraisemblable martinique
là nous sommes nous la voix de l'état a
étendu sa politique régaliennes en
martinique et ça ne m'étonne pas que
l'on trouvait déverser toutes les
politiques du gouvernement qu'elles
soient des politiques bonne chose ou pas
aujourd'hui il faut que les martiniquais
qui ont demandé c'est chez elles sont
habitées à simulation h il énonce les
personnes démissionnent de leur mandat
parce que nous sommes à l'heure là on ne
peut plus faire aucune de quoi que ce
soit merci d'avoir écrit ce matin avec
nos mario mauro on rappelle que vous
êtes sur trois militants associatifs du
genre ayant sociales johanna film rating
premier qui donne la parole aussi comme
d'autres médias mais qui permet aussi
d'aller à l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est
païens qui est la fête finie il faut pas
aller de chez eux autour des politiques
mais a su merci beaucoup